i'm very sorry to hear that because pat
robertson
is pretty tough as nails republican
pat robertson said my favorite phrase
maybe ever
in modern politics this guy said this is
in a 1992 fundraising letter he said
the feminist agenda is not about equal
rights for women it is about a socialist
anti-family political movement
that encourages women to leave their
husbands kill their children
practice witchcraft destroy capitalism
and become lesbians
you know and you listen to that you say
gosh that's that's
pretty pretty radical but much like
bertrand russell with the ontological
argument it's easier to think that he's
wrong and to quite point out the flaw in
his logic regardless pat robertson
no squish right he's never been a squish
he says
joe biden is going to be the president i
think it's all over
i think the electoral college has spoken
i think the
the biden uh corruption
has not totally been brought to
fruition but it doesn't seem to be
affecting the electoral college
and i don't think the supreme court is
going to move in to do anything
and i think we're going to see a
president biden
and i also think we'll be seeing a
president
campbell harris not too long after the
inauguration of president
biden that is so
depressing but listen to the way
pat robertson's talking at least when
he's opening up here he's not saying
this is what we should do
this is what i hope happens he's being
purely descriptive
he's saying look there were these
avenues to
challenge the results of the election
you could do it in court
and you can get to the legislative state
legislatures or before they
send their electors or to the electors
themselves
the court the courts i think have shut
down a lot of cases but in the
in the real tough cases where they
should have taken up the issue
where ted cruz said he was going to go
argue up before the supreme court
supreme court refused to get involved
they want nothing to do with this
they don't want to bush v gore they
don't want the attention so they refuse
to even hear the case so courts are out
you could get to the state legislature
well state legislature's already sent
their electors they didn't decertify the
vote so now what could the electors be
faithless could they could we challenge
the votes in congress in the house and
in the senate
yes there are some members who have said
they're going to challenge the votes
the the historical analog for that would
be the compromise of 1877. we actually
covered it on this show i think we're
the only show in politics that was
covering the compromise of 1877
to give some insight into this election
and the sad fact is
it does not seem that there is the
political will to do anything like that
so robertson totally descriptive here
saying
probably it's over but he went further
and and
actually went after trump a little bit
which made me quite
crestfallen with all
his talent and the ability of to raise
money and draw large crowds the
president
still lives in an alternate reality he
really does
people say well he lies about this than
the other but no he isn't lying
to him that's the truth he had the
biggest crowd on inauguration gay
he had he had more people than ever he
was the most popular
of people uh he saved nbc but with the
apprentice you could go down
the line of things that really aren't
true
and you know people kept pointing to
them
but because they loved him so much and
he was so strong for the evangelicals
the evangelists were with him all the
way
but there was something about him that
was good
that god placed him in that office for
the time he's done a marvelous job for
the economy
but at the same time he is very erratic
and he
uh he's fired people he's fought people
and he's insulted people and keeps going
down the line
so it's it's a mixed bag and i think
it would be well to say uh you've had
your day
and uh it's time to move on
you've had your day and it's time to
move on this this is
really sad it's sad for me to listen to
this
and i'm i'm not even look what if at
robertson's point is
trump's a complex guy and he's got many
great virtues and he's got some flaws
too that's true
uh that describes everybody except
everybody's got flaws not everybody has
heroic virtues or
record of accomplishment but i see his
point i see i see what he's saying
and this is going to be a question that
is debated for a while is president
trump
going to continue to lead the party is
he going to run again say in 2024
uh you know assuming that biden gets it
this time or
or not is he is he just gonna go away to
the side
you know i i see i i see that there is
an argument i understand the argument of
just go away you've had your time now
it's time for somebody else okay fine
people when they leave the presidency
they just often for ex-presidents it's
good when they go into obscurity
but here's my question who
follows trump who else are there a lot
of people who want to
who has the courage who has the
character who has the hutzpah
to follow trump i mentioned this at the
tpusa event the other day i said
i hope trump lives a very long time i
hope he has a very nice
long life when he when he eventually
goes as we all go
he may give his body to science i hope
he gives his spine to the gop
who's going to take up that trumpian
mantle who's going to fight like trump
fights
who's going to change the priorities
of the establishment and at least fight
the priorities of the establishment the
way
that trump did singularly i don't know
if trump leaves on january 20th
and if someone is willing to step up and
take that mantle
and fight and fight for that make
america great again agenda
then there's an argument for trump you
know supporting that person
if nobody does then i want that fight i
want trump to be fighting from outside
of the office and fighting to get back
in too
a lot remains to be seen
i i i don't have a whole lot of
confidence given this
covid relief bill quote unquote that
just came out of congress
i don't have a lot of confidence that
there are a ton of politicians out there
who can step up and who can speak up
and and perhaps robertson would agree i
don't know he hasn't consulted me on
this but
this is going to be pat robertson is a
representative
of a of serious you know
right-wing conservatives not squishy
republicans and of people who take their
religion seriously obviously
pat robertson's been a televangelist for
many many decades
describing the cultural issues the
feminist agenda
making people become witches and things
like that
[Music]
you